all right I guess it's
time so my name is Richard Campbell uh
that's my Twitter handle or my ex handle
or the social media for know as Twitter
handle easy way to reach me this uh
particular talk derives from another
talk I've been giving uh since
2019 when folks were asking like what do
you think is going to happen in the next
decade for software I make all these
podcasts about software development so I
get to talk to a lot of experts about
the various you know things that are
being developed and how things are
progressing and what we should be
looking forward to and so it makes it
easier for me to do some speculation
looking forward and when I wrote the
first version of 2019 I was thinking hey
we've got a new decade coming this is
going to be cool let's talk about what
software development is going to be like
in the 2020s not thinking by February of
2020 we were going to be thinking very
differently all of a sudden and so one
of the segments I put put in the next
decade talk was this mention of the
pandemic initially when I did the
version in 2020 I said look we're in a
pandemic we're trying to figure out what
that's going to be like but you can
expect it's going to have some impact on
how uh companies spend money you know
we're going to spend a lot of money
managing this problem uh between
developing medicines treating people
that are ill and that's going to have a
ripple through our whole economy me and
I sort of said kind of casually in all
of that you know as a developer we
usually don't worry a lot about that
sort of thing but it may come back to
haunt us so be more
aware uh and then by 21 it became more
obvious that was a problem and in 22 it
became really really obvious it was a
problem and so I ended up taking just
that comment that little segment in the
portion of the next decade talk and
making it into its own talk with which
is this one uh because for the most part
I think tech technology people software
people did just fine in the pandemic we
were working for a home before it was
cool right and our friend satcha said
that in a spe period of about two months
March April May we move more workloads
in the cloud in those couple of months
than they moveed the previous two years
sending everybody to work from home made
us find ways to solve problems and so
while it's not a big deal that we worked
from home I do think it's going to be an
interesting piece of history of watching
the rest of our companies sort of deal
with the zoom call effect like I almost
think there could be a Visual History of
Zoom because you have that remember that
first phase where everybody just had a
bad camera or no camera and we were all
muted I mean now just only one of us is
muted but mean what's Pro and then there
was that next phase when the snap cam
came out and everybody had a stupid hat
on or an animation running around the
frame then there was the pet phase when
everybody had to show their pet or their
baby on and now I I think we've evolved
an etiquette for video for companies now
where you see most people come on
initially to say hi and then a lot of
people shut the camera off right away
cuz we're a distraction or more
importantly we don't want to pay
attention anymore so I mean it literally
we've had a cra crazy few years of these
changes but getting back to the more
significant parts from uh you know is
not the pandemics really end they just
sort of wind down you know this was true
in
1918 you know that flu just kept coming
back in fact it does today it's
H1N1 it's just that 100 years on it's
not as lethal uh and we make vaccines
for it every year and this appears to be
what's happening with Co 19 as well and
likely we're going to continue to make
vaccines for it also but those three
years did have a lot of impact on
infrastructure we run we live in a
largely globalized world that the
interruptions that happened in different
parts of the world had Ripple effects
everywhere China's shutdown problems
affected an awful lot of shipping the
rush to move PPE to the West resulted in
huge numbers of empty containers being
left behind that have only just now
started to clear up the impact on Global
Supply Chain this just taken a long time
we found out that an awful lot of
companies that were working just in time
didn't cope with uh interruptions in
Supply and so partially finished
products everywhere uh that then got
damaged or were no longer suitable to be
finished so it's really a comp a complex
set of moving pieces that's gotten to
this point where the supply and
Interruption meant that people who had
demand for Key Products were willing to
pay for more for them and suddenly we
had inflationary effects now there's
inflation caused by monetary policy but
there's also inflation caused by demand
and behavior and the two kind of Ripple
against each other and so when you look
at the consequences of the pandemic we
did have an inflationary period that
caught a lot of governments by by
surprise we also had some cultural
changes folks being kept at home for a
few years started re-evaluating the way
they wanted to work and what they wanted
to do and at one point in 2022 we were
talking about that great resignation
that everybody sort of shuffled the jobs
around part of that I feel like was just
pent up demand while we were in this
crisis nobody was willing to quit and so
you suddenly had two or three years of
delay career changing all catch up at
once and that had an interesting KnockOn
effect to that crazy supply chain
problem because suddenly you had a lot
of new people in jobs especially jobs
that had been shut down for a while
because they didn't make sense during
the pandemic you know most systems are
can tolerate about a 5% inefficiency one
in 20 employees are new but what happens
when one in two employees are new whole
systems run less efficiently and things
take longer and that Cascades on other
problems and so we were threatened with
this pandemic economic collapse now did
it
happen that's a great question I mean
it's October of
23 and some of the numbers are are good
and some of the numbers are bad lots of
things are weird certainly earlier this
year the tech Giants decided that the
situation later in the the year was
going to be serious although one would
argue there's other forces acting on
that for example
Microsoft uh latest reported quarter
this is the second largest company in
the world by capitalization it's a $2
trillion capitalized company uh which is
an unbelievably huge number to conceive
of for 220,000 employees and in their
last quarter their gross revenues were
$56 billion and they netted 24 billion
on that which is an unbelievably good
ratio now I work pretty closely to M
with Microsoft so I was abundantly aware
that in
21 they hired almost 40,000 employees in
a year which is an insane number but
there was this concern with the pandemic
continuing that it didn't grab up folks
with some skills they were going to be
harder and harder to get by one would
argue that they over hired but the
consequence was was that early this year
they laid off 10,000 plus employees and
that put a scare into a lot of folks you
know Microsoft rarely lays people off
especially numbers as large as that
although it would argue in a 200,000
person company when you're laying off
10,000 people like it's barely
5% normal corporate turnovers like 2 and
a half to three so while it sounds like
a big number on paper it's not actually
that large number but it had a sort of
shock effect on the workers inside of
Microsoft and elsewhere in the tech
industry and this ripped across all of
the tech Giants so Google who also had
an unbelievable quarter like this past
quarter was 74 billion they made about1
18 billion and they really made it off
of exactly one product which is AD
Revenue that's what they that's what
Google does they keep trying to make
other things but nothing seems to make
quite as much money as sell as showing
you stuff you don't want to buy on every
website you can go to uh but they also
laid off 12,000 employees this past year
and for the most part have continued
hiring at the same
time and then Amazon is the Monster
again same quarter 134 billion but their
net was 7.7 on that because my Amazon
really isn't actually a tech company
they're a warehousing company they stock
un unbelievable arrays of products all
over the world and deliver them to to
you within a day or two as long as you
pay them hundred plus dollars a year for
Prime and uh they a lot of those workers
they've got a lot of them 1.9 million
employees they Li off something like
30,000 this year mostly in the
warehousing space although they did take
big chunks out of the Tech Community as
well and I would throw in meta here much
smaller fish in this pool especially bit
at the beginning of this year when the
change to meta and the idea that we're
all going to wear virtual glasses all
the time for social media seemed like a
good idea I mean only to one guy but he
had a lot of money and power so he tried
to make it come
true but uh they've got a little hipper
now with threads and some of the new
things they're doing but still this past
quarter 30 32 billion in Revenue netting
7.8 like we keep thinking that Facebook
is
doomed until you look at the numbers
you're like this company still makes a
giant pile of money and they don't have
that many employees it's only about uh
880,000 employees at beta and they laid
off about 15,000 of them over the course
of this past year and I throw all those
numbers at you just to say the anxiety
we've that a lot of tech folks have been
feeling this year has been that these
Tech Giants have done these layoffs and
that shocked a lot of the employees and
made them hunker down I think they they
this is almost a lashback against the
great resignation and the sense that
people want more from their work and at
the same time at least in the United
States unemployment is incredibly
low that most people who want a job have
a job there's an argument that in
Western economies you need about a 5%
unemployment label layer just to have
enough Mobility for people to move
around and work so anytime you see the
number below that it's actually kind of
problematic now there are higher
unemployment rates in other countries
and certainly Portugal struggles with
that uh they it's a different economy
here and they have their own set of
issues and across Europe in general
there are other issues going on here so
I don't just want to lean on pure us
numbers here that there are other uh
employment factors that go into it but I
do press the point that we're in an
industry that consistently hasn't been
able to fill 20% of its jobs the growth
of the workspace is faster than we can
train and that has literally been true
for
decades but there was a sense at the
beginning of this year with this wave of
layoffs and concern that maybe that was
over that there's a push back to that
well maybe we have enough and none of
the real numbers make this
true that actually there's still too
much work and while companies are
hesitating to hire it's mostly out of
fear not Financial desperation CU fear
is
enough if you're a business owner and
you're trying to decide whether you're
going to hire a few more people to move
a little faster but you're seeing the
tech Giants lay off and you're seeing
threats of recession an economic impact
from the pandemic maybe I hold a little
money back you a little more concerned
and so there was a sense of sort of
pushing back now when I was doing this
talk six months
ago there was a lot more weight on the
idea that by the end of this year
there's going to be a recession things
are going to be HED but we're kind of
here
now and there's still no sign of it and
I'm a pretty optimistic guy but I
haven't been laid off so it's pretty
easy to be optimistic when you still you
know have your income in play talk to
someone who has been and is struggling
to find the equivalent job they have
it's a bit tougher for them so I want to
be empathetic but at the same time like
the numbers aren't there that being said
as an old developer as someone who's
literally written code for 40
years I have gone through significant
economic hardship when I was a software
developer and it occurred to me in all
of the work that I do telling stories
that
it's been more than 20 years since
there's really been a downturn that
impacted software developers you know we
had a bit of an economic crisis in 2008
and
2009 but for the most part the
development industry was unaffected it
was a housing crisis caused primarily in
the US that rippled across the banking
sector so there were layoffs in the
Housing Industry there were layoffs in
the banking industry but most developers
just kept working so I'm going to let
that one go I kind of got to backup all
the way
to the end of the doom boom to like
2001 and at that time we were training
developers as fast as we could because
we needed to make more pets.com websites
like you couldn't make websites fast
enough and there were like 16 we boot
camps and now you're a web developer and
when that Madness finally ended a lot of
those folks had a tough time finding a
job and it scared people off of
development for a while and you know
I've seen this Gap where folks that were
making career decisions in the 20012
2002 time frames that whatever you do
don't go into software development
people lose their jobs there but if you
did go into software development at that
time you've had about a 20y year
run of pretty much there's more work
than you could possibly do what do you
want to work on like keep on going and
the possibility that that might Bobble
for a moment it's a pretty good one and
there's things we can do so for someone
like me who jumped into software
development in the 80s when we had a
widespread economic recession we thought
about software a lot more differently we
were way more con concerned with the
return on investment for software so
what am I really talking about well in
the end we write code for money because
our companies can take that code and
make more money with
it in theory anyway you know the real
question is how connected are you to all
of that it really come when we talk
about return investment we take about
how much does it cost for us to create
this software and how much return does
it have how long does it take and how
much does it cost and when will we make
that back in the benefits of that
software so it's a money question and
there's a bunch of ways to look at the
money around it it's like do you know
how your company makes money because
rarely for us as developers are we
directly attached to the revenue stream
of the
company we're indirectly attached we
tend to be staff opposed to L we make
tools to allow the folks that make the
money for the company to be more
effective which is highly leverageable
like when you do that well you can
substantially expand the ability of an
individual to bring in uh revenue for
the company so I'm not saying it's a
waste of time like that's good stuff
there's a reason we're digitizing the
economy and doing all these things the
question is are we properly connected to
it do you know how your company makes
money does what you're doing inside the
company save
money does it cost money does it make
money and often we're disconnected from
that we just don't need to worry about
those pieces at all so I want to talk
about some activities we can do as
developers with an eye to
Roi so just that mindset of what's the
value prop around it because without a
doubt there's work you can do inside of
an organization that makes you look very
busy it might even be work you're being
asked to do but is it actually providing
value because should there be an
economic concern or should the company
just be uncertain enough that they're
like maybe we should reduce the
workforce for a bit they are going to
pick the folks that provide the least
return and more importantly they won't
be picking the folks where they can
clearly see they and provide a
substantial value to the
organization so not one way to solve
this problem and no and there are many
things you can do so let's run through a
few of them and just consider some
possibilities the first is are you as
productive a developer as you could
be how well do you use your tools you
know the the hot new tool on the Block
is
co-pilot and if you haven't spent some
time with it maybe you should because
most developers who get engaged with
this tool and whatever platform you're
working on whatever language you like
working in I'm not going to need to sh
for Microsoft on this as much as
Microsoft has GitHub as a wholly owned
subsidiary GitHub co-pilot works on lots
of different platforms but it is a super
stack Overflow or at least it's a
mechanism for helping to produce code
quickly to get you over that blank
screen syndrome to help you with
language examples if you're not super
strong in a language so there's a lot of
ways you can use GitHub co-pilot and
it's well worth spending a little time
on that it's I think the name's
phenomenal the great thing about calling
a co-pilot is you're the pilot which
means it's all your
fault now then
as much as I have deep concerns about
chat GPT and large language models in
general and if you've been listening to
some of the stuff I've made I've been a
somewhat of a vocal critic a I don't
like
hype I think hype makes people do stupid
things and B no tool is perfect and if
you think your tool is perfect you're on
a path to failure and so my push was
always let's understand what this tool
is good at and what it's bad at that
being said this particular tool has two
things going for it the first is you you
write code and you read code and the
code it spits out sometime is crap but
sometimes it's pretty good ideas at
least it's a it's a creative stimulus
the software is not creative you're
creative but sometimes the software can
provide you ingredients to help
stimulate your creativity so it might
spit out a version of a particular
algorithm you have seen before Sparks
your ideas on how to write a better one
and if you get good with this tool this
is a productivity booster and in an
environment where we're concerned about
providing value to our organization
tools that can improve our productivity
are good
tools so it's not the only tool in the
Box you got to figure out how you like
to develop software but often we're too
busy doing the work to worry about the
tool uh Steven cvy is an old school
productivity guy has this book called
The Seven Habits three of them were
about managing your life better three of
them were about help were interacting
with others and the last one the number
seven was called sharpening the
saw and it was the idea that once in a
while you got to stop doing work and
improve your tools the line was always
guy working hard cutting down a big tree
with one of those big old saws back and
forth somebody asks them how long you
been doing that it's like oh 2 hours
it's like wow you're barely halfway
through have you thought about you know
sharpening the saw and he goes I got no
time for that I got to cut this tree
down often we're so busy building
software we don't think about if we're
actually building it the best way we
could be building it that maybe a day of
looking through our sweeted tools and
the way we're making things could find
some optimization that would make every
other day
better so I'm using copilot as the
Exemplar here just because it's new and
it does provide some distinct benefits
but everything you work in right now
it's worth scrutiny just a little time
maybe find some rewards and be the more
productive version of
yourself uh jump into another stack I
have paid close attention as someone who
works in software all the time on these
low code no code Solutions uh I pick on
Power Platform just because I often live
in Microsoft land and a lot of customers
have M365 already and they may or may
not be using this now if you're Prof a a
developer and it's dangerous to say
professional developer because what does
that make the Power Platform
person these are productivity tools that
build hetro genius clients quickly they
are a limited set of functionality
compared to the tools that we have
they're good at forms over data problems
but they spit out phone tablet and PC
clients quickly they need backend
services in the cloud to work they're
really only for Eternal apps by the way
that they're
licensed
but if you can get people to start
building those clients for you
especially people that know the domain
well so they're going to build the
client they would use it's not like you
were getting to the bottom of your to-do
list anyway like anything that can speed
that process up is useful Microsoft for
a while was talking about this
technology from the perspective of what
they called Fusion development that
there was a role for the developers
using the traditional visual studio type
tools to build components to work with
Power Platform tools uh we are seeing
this these products emerge and I know
this is an active area because there's
about 20 products in this place Power
Platform is one of them it's the
Microsoft one you know Amazon has honey
code Oracle has a
in but the fact that there's adversity
of them just sort of speaks to the fact
that we're at an inflection point in
forms over data development in the
cloud and when you're measuring yourself
on your ability to deliver features the
idea that you could have a tool that
would speed up that at least that client
side for you it's
interesting if not necessarily for you
to use to collaborate with those that
are using it because the combination of
your skills in the back end and their
skills in the front end deliver more
value and less
time we'll never be done with the cloud
conversation the cloud transformation
continues to go on I'm kind of liking
where we are at the moment we've gotten
over the Panic of the uh of the pandemic
where we moved workloads quickly I see a
little more right sizing going on these
days where folks are fig go hey that
thing doesn't run that well in the cloud
or it does run in the cloud but it's
really expensive like does that make
sense and some workloads are going back
on Prem the providers now and Microsoft
being among them are getting better at
talking about hybrid is the normal that
a certain amount of infrastructure stays
on premises certain amount of workloads
make sense in the cloud
especially when you're dealing with
folks that aren't in the office you know
the ability to proxy from a mult to
multiple locations is hard and so cloud
services help with an awful lot of that
now there are folks that not big fans of
that Cloud but those are mostly folks
that are looking at workloads from how
they were running on Prem and just
shifting them directly to Cloud which
arguably is the worst way to do it it's
fast doesn't require as many changes but
you are thinking infrastructure I'm
using someone else's computer that I can
pay for by the minute now typically when
I built out systems for my
companies uh myself I provisioned for
Peak you figure out what's the maximum
load for a given application that's
going to run on a set of infrastructure
and you buy to that because that's all
the infrastructure you have and you'll
deal with the fact that half the time
it's not being used and once in a while
it's going to go all the way to the top
but it's not a real practical way to do
stuff in the cloud and you don't need
to so when I talk about projects that
provide substantial rois to companies I
talk about moving up the cloud stack so
when you're running on premise you own
everything storage networking all the
way up you're patching operating systems
or at least somebody is and your apps
are being deployed on that your quick
flip to the cloud you virtualize the
servers now you pay for them by the
hour but it can be expensive to do it
that way you got rid of buying the
hardware but you're still paying for
provisioning for Peak you can tune this
but as you move further up the stack
into the platform pieces
now you're needing fewer virtual
machines and more of the platform pieces
that you only you pay for with
utilization you get more elasticity
until you can get all the way up the
stack where as much as virtualized as
POS as possible and you can uh only pay
for what you consume and this is where
the pricing gets really
decent we can do this it just takes time
the trick is proposing projects like
this so because often we're a feature
cycle you know our employers used to was
just cranking new features out and maybe
those features aren't going to be the
highest return if you start speaking
business back to them about being more
efficient and spending less to get the
same results these kinds of projects
start to make more sense to them too you
know there's nothing like a big fat
Amazon bill to at least get the CFO
saying why why does this cost so much
and what can we do about it and you can
start proposing projects that largely
move up the stack should be able to
reduce those bills and get better
results for you these are really
measurable Roi
projects often we're building software
where it's harder to see the value and
so going onto these while they may not
be as sexy they're still interesting
problems but they do provide various
obvious value to your organization and
because they they do they will cost less
you will save the company money money
that could be applied to other things
elsewhere all right let's get a little
more abstract that's pretty much still
Plumbing related stuff uh let's talk
about refactoring of software this was
another problem that I found extensively
post pandemic or even during the
pandemic so what do we talk about M
multi Channel versus onni Channel often
organizations build a line of work uh in
a silo so they have retail outlets and
they have warehousing to supply multiple
re retail outlets supplies come from
that warehouse to the retail
stores that's fine returns go back into
the warehouse like that's all of that
works then they decide they need an
online presence so they build a website
but they probably may not feed off of
the same channel at all they might even
run a separate Warehouse just for
supplying web because they go to now the
distribution is largely done by shipping
so rather than making it close to where
Shoppers would be they make it close to
where the transport hubs are so you have
a warehouse for your web supply sales
and you have a separate warehouse for
your store suppli sales I saw companies
get into the situation the pandemic
where their web stores ran out of stock
but their retail stores were full of
stock because the stores were closed and
their warehouses didn't even have it
available because they've never
Consolidated the pieces
together and you you've run into this if
you've ever bought bought something
online and you had to return it by
mailing it back you couldn't take it to
the store or return it Omni channel is
the idea that it doesn't matter where I
buy it or where I get service from it
all of the methodologies work I can go
into the store I can go online I can
work from my phone we treat it all
equally it's harder than it looks and
most organizations didn't think on the
channel at the beginning so they have a
set of silos in
place this is a hug huge Roi project
it's also really flipping hard to
do you know what you need to make this
work
diplomacy because you're now there's a
reason those different Stacks are
separated from each other they are run
by different people and they may not
like each other and the idea that we're
all going to work and play well with
each other to bring those pieces
together that's hard work but hugely
valuable and so you may you can look
into your own organization and say is
there a space here where we have
separate Stacks that we shouldn't and
maybe being able to combine them
together would make a difference for the
organization it's not a feature-based
product even you know it's not the
obvious thing but is a valuable thing
and it certainly creates substantial
value in you to be able to solve these
classes of
problem now doesn't mean we can't build
Innovative software lots of folks are
excited about the new technologies that
out there if you want to bring machine
learning into your organization go for
it image recognition is a good one just
sometimes it's hard to see the value in
all of it right like that's the
challenge for us when we want to write
new software our image recognizers do
what we wanted to
do I wish I had made this picture up
it's a totally reasonable thing for a
piece of software to do right to do
multiple recognizers on on a given
image these kind of Technologies the
challenge is finding the ROI them you've
got to really work from a hypothesis
basis that if we add this capability to
this software it's going to approve
these things that trickle into value to
customers so they buy more or that it
costs us less to service that customer
higher levels of satisfaction and often
we don't work that problem like we just
don't think through the value at that
level but if you go into a project like
this it's more speculative these are the
first projects that can be cut
if there's going to be cuts and it can
make you
vulnerable now chat PT is hot without a
doubt you know life was pretty peaceful
up until November of
2022 uh and if you followed the actual
story it's been many years in
development then nobody set out to big
do a Big Splash in November 22 they had
gotten to a point with gpt3 where they
were having problems they they'd run low
on money um for training sets and so
they basically open open it up to the
public to be able to give so that we
would feed them training data ask us new
prompts get and get new results back and
I think because we did it over Christmas
everybody got a little existential with
the software which is weird you know get
a dog but anyway it happened the way it
happened and 100 million people signed
up for chat GPT in two months and that
was kind of a magic
number you know that's the fastest for
to 100 million of anything ever and so
the whole tech industry kind of went a
little nuts starting with Microsoft who
had heavily invested in open AI early on
not knowing this would happen but they
they saw an opportunity to move those
workloads onto Azure and so they took it
years before and now here they were and
then uh Altman proposed a GPT 4 which
required one of the largest
supercomputers ever built out of cloud
infrastructure to compute um Microsoft
gave them $10 billion in Azure credits
not cash Azure credits and they spent
it that's a lot of
azure to build a model now that costs a
lot of dollars to operate so you're
seeing in the news the conversations
about they're losing $20 a month per
person for GitHub co-pilot which is just
a that's a flyer for saying hey it ain't
going to be 10 bucks a month much longer
the question is is still valuable $30 a
month which you know you don't need very
many good ideas from that tool before 30
bucks in a month is a deal so you know
we're in early days for this technology
and we're still feeling around what the
value prop is going to be I do think
there's a lot of heat on folks to say
how are we going to incorporate this
this is provide a competitive Advantage
not just that it's cool and you've
certainly seen talks here this week
about incorporating large language
models in software I watched Phil's ha
Phil hack talk from the hallway cuz the
room was completely filled which is an
interesting sign Microsoft's clearly
running hard on this they keep
rebranding it clearly they've grabbed
github's name co-pilot for a while there
was there's going to be an M365 co-pilot
there's a security co-pilot and there's
a Windows co-pilot and now they're just
saying Microsoft
co-pilot but really they're a platform
company which means they want to have
you build co-pilots and the idea of
having a large language model over top
of your company is an interesting one
that possibly could provide some
substantial value and I hope you're
paying attention to some degree there I
find this more speculative for the value
proposition this is because we're in
such early days but I also say hey if
leadership really wants it and you're
the one who facilitates it that's
another way to keep your job for sure so
you know as much as the the the old
cynical engineer in me looks at this and
goes I think I'd let that cook for a
little while long longer you know in net
rocks I'm making podcasts every
week and so I have already pushed back
on everybody who wants to talk about
making large language models to say show
me the money show me the project in the
field that's providing benefit I'll put
that show on by the way I have a couple
they'll be coming out the next month or
so so there are folks that are being
successful with that and I'm feeling
like I'll serve you as the guy who makes
the podcast to make sure we're talking
about real stuff not speculative stuff
but the amount of energy that exists
around this provides its own
cover okay less speculative more
concrete but far less
sexy our companies collect a lot of data
and they simply don't do enough with it
plain and simple if you want to provide
value to your organization in a big
hurry get better at data analytics
in the old days we had Predictive
Analytics models and all these different
styles of analysis the fractal time
series The the Elliot waves all of these
kinds of things back in the '90s you
would spend months analyzing your data
to decide which of these data mining
algorithms made sense for your compute
these days you don't do that anymore the
Cloud's fast enough and cheap enough
that if you've got your data up there
you can run all of
them and then compare them pick which
one you like the best results wise so
we've gotten made it much easier to get
into Predictive Analytics models and now
with the modern machine learning tools
coming on and this is not llms like llms
have kind of overwhelmed the thinking
right now but before chat GPT we were
doing machine learning in useful ways we
were using neural Nets to analyze data
and the combination of Predictive
Analytics and machine learning models is
powerful because it allows us to extract
more value from data to get bigger
insights into where companies are going
what uh numbers are available to
them you notice I haven't said
artificial intelligence until now
because it's a stupid
phrase artificial intelligence is was
coined in the
1950s by a set of scientists that were
trying to raise money from the military
the first time the public heard the
phrase artificial intelligence was 2001
of Space Odyssey in 1968 and then Hal
tried to kill everybody
so you know setting up the relationship
with the term generally speaking when
I'm talking to companies about hey we
want to incorporate AI into the
organization I'm like okay what do you
mean when you say that and most of the
time they don't
know also you use that term when the
technology doesn't work because the
moment it does work it gets a new name
you know yeah they keep calling chat GPD
AI because it's good for fundraising but
it's a large language
model and Predictive Analytics is can be
done with machine learning models and
when combined with uh with deeper data
models can actually get in this idea of
prescriptive analytics so now you're
cycling
actions against the data that it
generates to do additional
prediction this technology is starting
to spread fairly far if you've ever gone
to an e-commerce site thrown some stuff
in a shopping cart just to see what it
looked like and then abandoned the cart
and then you know a day or two later you
get an email about that cart you're
being prescriptively
analyzed they're seeing if they can
prompt you to come back right and it's
literally being done strictly with
software just that hey it works if
someone has been to my site and gone so
far as to throw stuff in the cart to
send an email about related products
around that sometimes I'll get results
from that and they'll analyze those
results and feedback into the next
Loop we can get deep ly into analyzing
data and building these models and
software around it because when you get
it right it makes the company a lot of
money you are now extracting additional
value from existing customers and
finding new sales for existing products
the most profitable work that most
companies can do looking for new
products and new customers is expensive
compared to getting yield from your
existing customers and you existing
products and analyzing the data that
your company already has is a very
effective way to get those kind of
results
okay uh often we're building valuable
software and we just don't know it we
have no idea if the feature we've just
written and deployed is even being used
except from the
complaints right rarely do we actually
measure positive results the modern
Telemetry tools and I point to open
Telemetry we talked to charity Majors
yesterday about this
they help us to measure the utilization
of tools if you want to create an effect
like really show the value in your work
one of the things is to measure the
results of the products that you build
the features that you put out there
putting Telemetry in them so that you
can use contemporary tools to analyze
that data makes it far easier for you
toite write a results report all too
often we pass the test and it goes into
the cicd pipeline and we don't think
about the code right ever again we just
send it off an ether that's somebody
else's problem and that's not owning
your Roi the return on your software
comes from its utilization not its
creation and so if you don't you look at
its utilization how do you know if
you're doing anything
useful measuring results is a part of
the devops pipeline is just that often
while we've talked about this great
cycle of planning coding building
testing releasing and
deploying almost no one's looking across
the entire cycle you know often this is
just a relationship between people that
once it got into the pipeline and got
released you never thought about it
again and the Ops guys were dealing with
it living out in the world operating it
and monitoring it and maybe they fed
back to the designers some of the
results to then be pushed back to you
for new construction but it's seem your
best interest ultimately to know how
your software is being used ask for the
reports who's looking at this stuff what
is the result of the software that's
being that we're building is it being
used and is it being tuned you know
second pass on a feature or you often
get a bunch of better results I got into
this habit because I pushed out a
feature and this is in the '90s that
people use in a way I hadn't even
thought of and it took the system out in
a week and when I went back and looked
at the logs that I'd never bothered
looking at before you could see the
signs of this data was growing out of
control because folks were using the
feature in a way I hadn't expected and
so I got into a habit of you roll the
feature out and then you watch the logs
to see how it's being utilized and then
I would write a little summary up to my
manager saying hey push this feature out
over the past week this many people have
used it they use it this many times
we're seeing some additional resources
being consumed here I you know might
want to go back and do some optimization
here or maybe we need to buy another
server just some insight because it
otherwise wasn't being
scrutinized and I mean I hope it's
happening in your organization anyway
but you should ask and you should know
because it's part of you understanding
your value often we're writing software
we can double the performance of pieces
of our company but we never talk about
it we never are aware of it you know a
good sales manager if they can raise
sales 10% like they get a big bonus
they've killed it
we write software that can double
productivity that person used to process
100 orders now they process 200 orders
we never get a bonus for that mostly
because we don't own the ROI we're not
paying attention to how our software
gets used we've have this cycle most
organizations are doing this to some
degree it's only a question of how
strong it is if you don't look at it if
you don't participate in it deeply it's
hard to know that you're doing something
useful all right let's have a couple of
calls to
action first first spend time to learn
we're often too busy working to actually
spend some time working on the skills
now I'm probably talking to the wrong
group of people because you're here
you've taken a week off gotten away from
the office you were looking forward to
the portal weather and you were
denied so you stayed in the room but
maybe I learned a few things and I hope
you carry that back to your
organizations and help others learn from
it too you know you want to be the one
that always gets sent to the conference
be the one that teaches from what you
learned at the conference it's a good
way to go the folks who can express the
value that that that they put into an
event like this can help folks a lot but
it's taking a little time for you to
always improve your own skills and find
new opportunities can help everyone
around you as well as yourself do spend
some time thinking about
Roi where are we providing value are we
working on the right things does it pro
does it benefit the customer how how
will we know when we did a good job
you know shipping's not enough how we
know when we did a good
job what was the benefit to the company
what was the benefit to the the customer
just we often don't ask those questions
and now for the most inappropriate slide
in my whole
deck hunt sacred cows this is not funny
in India India India it's a little funny
here what am I actually talking about
it's an old Mark Twain line that said
it's not what you know it's what you
know no ain't so go after the
assumptions things that you think are
always true but may not be true and let
me give you an example this is the map
of the world it's just wrong but it's
the map of the world that we were taught
as kids this is a mercor projection map
from the
1500s it keeps the latitude
symmetrical to make it easier for
Navigators to work but it also disto
supports the equator making it smaller
and it stretches the poles to make them
dramatically bigger we have better Maps
the Peters projection map is an area
rule
map this is a better representation of
our world except for the one problem it
looks really
wrong because this is the thing we've
always been
taught and this is what happens to
actually
be Africa is the secondar largest
continent it doesn't looks at here
doesn't look at here you know Africa and
South America almost look the same right
but it's simply not true this is an
assumption that you knew the shape of
the world it's an easy one to make we've
been taught
this can you
learn there's a better
map how many other assumptions are in
our heads and they're hard to find
because they are assumptions right there
things we've been taught all along and
it's good to just ask the questions
press against some of those things say I
know we believe this but why you know
what what is it that comes from that and
the map is just a one example of that
and it's a lot easier on the
cows but I'll wrap up with this when we
talk about what comes next from all of
these
things we are very fortunate as
technology people to figure out what
comes next because most of the time we
get to make it what we build for our
organizations shape those organizations
the question is are we building the
right things it's really up to us and I
hope you'll do the right thing too
thanks so much for your
[Applause]
time